afternoon everyone have a seat
grab a cup of coffee and a moment oh
also a reminder that the seminar rooms
are a weapons free zone
please make sure you've surrendered your
weapons at the reception desk I know
it's [ __ ] but the last thing I need
is an o-5 complaining because one of you
was walking around the Blue Zones with
your peace everyone good cool today's
seminar is about a subject near and dear
to my heart
reality vendors type greens Mary Sue's
Bigsby shapers Wizards God's Devils
outside observers call them what you
will these are the guys that change
reality based on perception and
willpower I've made a career out of both
containing and killing these guys you're
here to get certified to do the same
thing want to know my secret we'll get
to that later
first of all I want you to take a look
at the doors to the seminar room notice
something about them look again what
doors yes the doors are gone take a
closer look if you want touch them
they're not there the doors have
literally disappeared but that's okay
right you can still get out of the
windows if you want except there's one
small problem there aren't any windows
in this room either are there all the
windows are gone there's nothing but
four blank walls a ceiling and a floor
no way out but how did you get in
starting to freak out a little bit don't
worry just take a deep breath you're
gonna be all right
just a bit of a change to the way the
room set up it's not like anything worse
is happening
I mean it could be worse right at least
you're safe in here it's not like the
desks are coming alive to kill you now
is it oh wait yes they are the [ __ ]
desks are going to kill you what are you
gonna do how are you gonna survive the
room is alive I'm going to eat you watch
for these [ __ ] desks they've got tea
get the [ __ ] away from there yeah you
want to live you're gonna have to fight
[ __ ] this is real this is
happening this is a reality you're going
to die
[Music]
and that's all you [ __ ] are going to
be you're going to be nothing but toys
for this broad kid for all eternity
there is no escape
there is no respite you live when I say
live you die only for a lolly there is
nothing left but my imagination you are
all figments of it
alright it delights everyone breathe in
and out deep breaths breathe in breathe
out in out are you all feeling better
now let me tell you what just happened
each and every one of you has just had a
bad trip although the food on that back
table was laced with a powerful
hallucinogen it's my own personal recipe
in addition to hallucinations it renders
one very susceptible to suggestion
combined with some simple hypnosis and
some special effects trickery the end
result is as close as we can get to
showing you what a reality benders
attack feels like the support staff are
pumping an aerosolized counter agents
into the air vents as we speak and it's
gonna feel like [ __ ] in the moment you
know find barf bags under your chairs
take a moment to let it all out
now I want you to reflect back on that
moment when you realized what was
happening
do you remember what it felt like to
realize the reality no longer existed
and you were nothing but toys for a
hostile will that controlled everything
remember that and hold on to it the
first time you're about to go up against
a reality bender if you ever think that
maybe you can contain them or maybe they
can be reasoned with remember what it
felt like when you were tripping balls
and nothing was real then uh-oh I killed
the [ __ ] before he knows you're
even there you're all certified now
class dismissed